et sur karembeu mesdames messieurs
bonsoir
alors christian m'a beaucoup
d'admiration pour vous un avenir vous
admire beaucoup pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que vous faites partie des
bleus dont vous êtes une star et
deuxièmement parce que vous êtes le mari
d'adriana karembeu
qu'on a tous admirer ici de nombreuses
fois et qu'on est prêt à tenir encore
très souvent je te le dit adriana alors
voilà vous continuer la saison prochaine
en angleterre a mis de beaux lots non
vous savez pas pour l'instant je n'en
sais trop rien vous savez pas réunies au
psg non plus j'en sais rien ah oui c'est
pas ça en train de se discuter là ça par
luiz après c'est comme à la télé c'est
le moment du mercato la main exactement
pour vous changer de place non moi je
moi je suis bien battue va bien ici là
sur france 2 bien alors christian donc
vous êtes kanak
karembeu servir l'homme en colère c'est
ça non dites moi si je me trompe ouais
c'est ça ça veut dire karembeu c'est
quelqu'un c'est un statut guerrier c'est
quelqu'un c'est très réduit je crois que
dans la nuit des temps dans tous les
peuples du monde en donner des noms par
rapport à la nature aux arbres et aux
pierres
c'est un guerrier à karembeu là vous
êtes né en 1970 salifou près d'ouvéa en
nouvelle-calédonie donc qu'on appellera
la kanaky bientôt ça va être indépendant
la nouvelle calédonie lancé en un
instant semi d'indépendance alors d'une
histoire terrible dans votre famille qui
a été révélé par didier daeninckx dans
un livre s'appelle les cannibales c'est
que les ancêtres de christian karembeu
ont été emmenés en métropole comme on
disait à l'époque pour être exhibée à
l'exposition slovenian de 1931 c'est une
histoire absolument terrible on les a
mis nu dans une case jeunesse de
répliques grotesque d'une vraie case
kanak on les a mis dans des costumes
exotiques on les a obligés à manger de
la viande crue et on est présenté comme
des cannibales polygame c'était un petit
peu l'attraction comme ça de cette foire
exposition d'infraction vedette et
ensuite ce qui est terrible c'est qu'ils
ont été échangés avec un zoo le zoo de
hambourg contre les crocodiles certes
après ils sont partis aux autres
vous saviez pas voir c'était on n'en
parle pas de ça chez vous n'en parlez
pas parce que c'était honteux d'en
parler ouais cela dit j'en ai moi j'en
ai profité par-delà mon statut de
pouvoir sensibiliser les gens d'abord
sur mon pays sur mon peuple et bien sûr
parler des miens vie ouais
je ci étant quand il le massacre d'ouvéa
des kanak ont été achevés des kanaks qui
se rendaient les mains en l'air ont été
achevés par par des gens qui portaient
l'uniforme de la république c'est un peu
la même chose d'une certaine façon et
c'est pas si vieux nom s'est jamais vu
enfin je crois que il faut toujours
mettre chaque situation dans son
contexte
l'époque des biens c'était justement le
pouvoir colonial qui existaient qui
existe toujours d'ailleurs et part de
par ce fait la france a voulu démontrer
justement l'étendue de son pouvoir que
vous étiez petit on vous a appris nos
ancêtres les gaulois
exactement ça fait
bien en fait comme j'étais petit vous
étiez plus intéressés par le foot et les
footballeur que par l'école et vous
connaissiez les joueurs de football par
la télé bien sûr mais aussi par les
magazines par des magazines comme france
football comme son onze 1 nous été
repéré par un ancien footballeur
professionnel marc gagnant qui a dit il
faut l'envoyer en métropole pour pour le
former alors votre maire
j'étais un peu voulu être médecin vous
demandiez ce n'était pas mieux de rester
là bas et d'être maître ça et finalement
vous êtes parti au centre de formation
de nantes le départ ça doit être
terrible avec tout le monde qui c'est
toujours difficile de de se séparer du
cocon familial
surtout dans ma culture où on est très
dense la tribu voilà exactement 1 est
nombreux plus est
mais je crois qu'il y avait jamais envie
de casser un peu cette
cette osmose mais en ôtant grandir
surtout quand vous montez dans l'avion
bon d'être un peu triste un peu comme ça
les larmes aux yeux puis quand les
portes se referment vous dites voilà il
faut que j'ai simplement ici ménard mais
on va il faut que je revienne avec au
moins une vraie quelque chose mais on
bosse et réussi alors quand vous arrivez
quand vous arrivez en métropole alors
évidemment vous allez c'est le mois
d'octobre il fait froid vous avez des
sandales c'est pas du tout habillés pour
la saison et en décembre un jour vous
habitiez près de la gare un jour vous
regardé par la fenêtre et tout est blanc
vous descendez en qu'elles sont dans la
rue vous faites un tour pieds nus dans
la neige que j ai jamais vu de neige
donc c'était beaucoup d' étonnant basse
et
c'est mary de pouvoir rencontrer quelque
chose qu'on ne connaît pas andré une
fois très ouvert la découverte en fait
parce que
[Musique]
ma philosophie est justement de toujours
connaître autant de monde l'homme sont
les découvrir mais avec émerveillement
et je suis toujours surpris ajournement
surpris de connaître ce que je connais
mais voilà alors vous imaginez en plus
que la métropole c'est des gratte-ciel
cdd truc ultra moderne est en fait vous
êtes très impressionné à nantes parce
que c'est des vieilles maisons et vous
dit toujours j'ai l'impression que je
vais croiser d'artagnan pas parce que
l'excès tout ça est assez antique maison
on peut rencontrer des pavés d'ailleurs
hier encore là le château de la duchesse
anne qui existent encore
les promenades de la loire où les
châteaux événement existe autour de la
noire glossy
donc là ça m'a permis de revenir en
arrière de pouvoir côtoyer pas côtoyer
mais au moins revivre des images de cape
et d'épée et j'ai pensé à d'artagnan les
transférer vers moi voilà bombay après
il ya toute l'histoire l'équipe de
france dernier match de l'équipe de
france contre le japon
regarde le match contre le ghana bat
contre le japon c'est le 24 mars 2001 il
a eu un problème c'est la fédé sifflé
contre vous quand vous avez remplacé
lizarazu à la 79e minute pourquoi tous
ces sifflets
je n'en sais rien mais jamais été
victime de racisme en france non
heureusement non non et même mes
oreilles ce serbe ouais mais pas
d'accord
non parce que je crois que le riz le
silence ait une meilleure réponse arrêt
comme le proverbe c'est ce que tu as à
dire est moins beau que le silence alors
tais toi
on sait pas quand c'est pas que les mecs
qui sont à répéter tout ça
pensez pas que les mecs lucide qui sont
jaloux parce que vous êtes avec adriana
je sais pas mais si je crois que c'est
ça commence avec elle l'a très bien
parce que
l'éminent d'éloges non
la seconde annonce régulièrement votre
séparation mais tout va bien tu va très
bien tout va très bien très bien voir
comment ça s'est passé
deuxièmement je connais dans un bus
super connue vous connaissez dans un bus
d'aéroport
connaissez pas le tombe sur un type qui
lui dit je pêche moins intelligent la
question vous mesurer combien déjà voilà
comment draguer adriana karembeu et ben
vous vous saviez même pas qu'il était un
puissant levier pas que c'était un grand
grand joueur de foot lui pensait j'ai
aucune chance il se dit tu vois vraiment
aucune chance tout le monde pendant 100
ans vous voyant et vous vous y est vous
vous dites quand les hommes me voient
ils pensent toujours j'ai aucune chance
et voilà ne marchera jamais alors que
c'est pas vrai
ils ont consommé
les imprimés bien sûr non mais mes sauts
son mari un signal concret doit
s'adresser l'homme oui mais il faut le
dire parce que je dirais bon tous les
deux alors c'est fou le couple étant
selon parce qu'on ne regarde personne
d'autre mais je vous donne quand ils
arrivent mais lui il s'est vraiment un
très bel homme donc il est dit j'ai pas
ma chance mais j'y crois pas trop grave
mais c'est quand même quelques mois josé
bové si vous si vous rencontriez adriana
karembeu dans un bus d'aéroport vous lui
diriez quoi pour la branche est est ce
que vous lui diriez comme fer avec 22
vous diriez quoi josé sérieux
que vous mais il faut que je dise pareil
en fait oui combien vous mesurer combien
c'est trop tard
autre chose voilà et donc alors après
bon ils montent dans l'avion tous les
deux vous d'habitude fait semblant de
dormir quand vous êtes dans un avion là
vous gardez un oeil ouvert
il se met à côté d'elle et puis voilà
bien la fin du voyage il vous a laissé
son chapeau ça c'est un truc à savoir
avec adriana karembeu faut laisser son
chapeau c'est là beaucoup ça vous a
touché oui parce que qu'est-ce que je
peux faire qu'est ce que je vais faire
avec un chapeau c'était un peu
parce que t'es mignon parce qu'elle me
disait j'ai rien j'ai rien sur moi elle
n'avait pas même pas même pas le valises
rien alors je m'adonnais voilà et alors
vous lui donnez votre numéro de
téléphone quand même assez rapidement la
première fois vous avez donné c'est vrai
normalement je sais pas ça j'espère bien
alors deux jours plus tard il vous
appelle et
vous l'inviter à prendre un café mais
comme vous êtes à milan élu à paris
demain qui prend un avion là c'est déjà
plus déjà plus fort la vitamine on t'en
fais pas j'arrive
c'est fort et la gagner et un an après
dans un restaurant fin du deuxième conte
de fées un an après dans le restaurant
il prend votre main comme ça sous la
table il enlève votre vieille bague et
ceux qui restent à une vague géante
vous êtes fait beau hélas bail de votre
maman et de notre papa non il lui dit
veux tu être ma femme tu es le mec que
des trucs simples combien vous mesurer
ce que tu vas être ma femme tu fais mon
chapeau nous on se fatigue des
dirigeants je fais de la fée blonde pas
du tout quelle est alors la faute de
notre mieux son trou de boue fondeur
larmes à la fin du deuxième
voilà
bravo
bravo alors vous dites au départ j'étais
pas séduit par la plastique d'adriana
mais fasciné parce qu'elle est dans son
âme oui
oui parce que nous pauvres cons et on
aurait
signé d'abord par sa plastique non non
pour ses revenus je crois qu'elle venait
de finir un
clip un travail en fait donc été ni bien
maquillée ni dray oui donc les cheveux
ébouriffés
sa prestance son allure elle m'a plus et
après quand j'ai pu lui parler voilà
mais vous dites après le vol milan paris
j'étais incapable de la décrire
physiquement donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui s'est passé au niveau du
regard effectivement mais lui du regard
du dialogue oui
on vous dit je suis tellement conscient
de l'est mais que je ressens pas le
besoin de multiplier les démonstrations
d'amour ce qu'elle me reproche parfois
lorsque je rentre exténués et que je
m'affale devant la télé christian merde
non j'emmerde n'ont pas su en fait
ça ce sont ces décès un petit détail
mais je crois que un sentiment on le
donne avec intégrité et on ne donne pas
pour jouer ou bien alors adriana était
là en novembre
on lui a fait l'interview alerte aux
roses est alors aujourd'hui on va vous
poser les mêmes questions pour savoir si
vous répondez pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle est votre première pensée lorsque
vous vous retrouvez face à une femme
séduisante
c'est une base suffisante ouais ouais
c'est la suffisance et des réponses est
quand même adriana lit depuis que j'ai
rencontré christian je ne pense plus à
rien lorsque je me trouve en face d'un
homme séduisant
ne croyez pas
je n'en sais trop rien
alors pourquoi qu'on continue le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte pour vous
comment cacher loin
[Musique]
elle répond total elle dit le lieu idéal
pour une étreinte c'est partout si je
suis avec la bonne personne
non mais c'est intéressant de voir
bubons ya peut-être une ouverture
l'endroit est chaud l'endroit où vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour fou
enfin
parce que vous pensez l'amour ces
sédiments faire le coït mais moins
l'amour c'est aussi dans le regard donc
c'est sûr partout oui c'est vrai nous on
est un peu
les français on est comme des sauvages
elle est répandue dans l'espace elle a
dit dans l'espace je pourrais pas faire
l'amour dans l'espace parce que j'aurais
peur
je voudrais demander à venir alors je
vous préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer
plus deux mais elle sait se faire
draguer est ce que vous préférez largué
ou vous faire larguer
mes salariés au moins j'ai rien à
l'objet d'accord elle dit je préfère
être celle qui l'a celle qui part est ce
que vous préférez embrasser ou vous
faire embrasser
embrasser elle aussi est sous préfet rey
caresser ou vous faire caresser
j'aime bien
est-ce qu'ils aient encore des fantasmes
que vous n'avez pas réalisé
si j'en ai oui j'en ai pas réalisé non l
vies with beaucoup vous y coller quand
même que si on part été
arrêté jusqu'à leur répond il faut
arrêter de regarder la télé si vous
deviez choisir la moitié d'une femme ou
pendriez le haut ou le bas
la moitié d'une femme
mariée le haut ou le bas
le haut le bas
mais la femme n'existe pas en une moitié
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu